[Musica]
buonasera a tutti
la storia che vi racconterò questa sera
comincia con una traversata in kayak
fatta con due amici nel lontano 2000 15
molti di noi sono attratti da parentesi
di isolamento di immersione nella natura
incontaminata ma a questa forza
centrifuga spesso si accompagna la forza
opposta una forza di coesione che ci
porta a cercare di stare con altre
persone
fu così anche per noi che attraccati con
i kayak le pagaie su una città
sconosciuta fumo paesi dalla smania di
incontrare persone di raccontare le
nostre storie di ascoltarla di nuovo
insomma dalla smania di contaminarci
sorseggiando una birra sul lungomare
ragionammo che si abbiamo una
un'infinità di strumenti digitali a
nostra disposizione per incontrare gli
altri ma in realtà sono degli oggetti
il denominatore comune della nostra
esperienza condivisa ci sono oggetti che
ascoltano insieme a noi la musica di un
dj che vedono i panorami che noi ci
godiamo e che ascoltano da sempre
silenziosamente il farsi e disfarsi
delle nostre relazioni sociali
al terzo giro di birra pensammo che
forse c'è un oggetto che più di tanti
altri a un punto di vista privilegiato
su questo mondo sporchi e sudati dalla
traversata
ci immaginiamo che un bicchiere
intelligente potesse raccogliere
informazioni e conservarle per futura
memoria
e ancora di più potesse insieme ad altri
bicchieri che ha una rete per arrivare
alle altre persone in tempo reale mentre
stanno bevendo in pubblico e quindi
presumibilmente che anche loro vogliano
contaminarsi pesate le persone in media
bevono otto volte al giorno
la metà di queste fuori casa non
ambiente pubblico il nostro mondo in
modo occidentale ogni volta che ci
troviamo insieme per far qualcosa di
bello che sia musica arte spettacolo
cinema politica
alla fine si beve qualcosa risultato è
che il bicchiere è l'accessorio
imprescindibile della nostra
convivialità questa idea l'idea di un
bicchiere intelligente rimase nel
cassetto perché nel 2015 facevo
tutt'altro ricercatore all'università di
gerusalemme ma continuò ad affascinarmi
e continuando affascinare moltissime
altre persone con cui mi capitò di
parlarne in realtà al fascino non è
nuovo è il fascino che abbiamo per
tantissimi oggetti che a cui de put
chiamo ruolo di conservare pezzetti
della nostra storia collettiva per
futura memoria
pensate a i diari delle medie su cui
tutti i compagni di classe scrivono la
dedica la caratteristica interessante di
questi oggetti che potremmo chiamare
oggetti coscienti è il fatto che ad ogni
utilizzo aumentano di valore perché ad
ogni utilizzo hanno la possibilità di
intercettare e conservare delle nostre
esperienze
il risultato è che questi oggetti da
usati valgono più di nuovi questo
interessante perché questa categoria di
oggetti soggetti coscienti opposta a
un'altra categoria di oggetti che invece
azzera elimina il proprio valore dopo un
utilizzo il primo sto parlando degli
prodotti usa e getta che sono un enorme
calamità naturale potremmo dire e se
siamo qua oggi questa sera e oggi questa
giornata anzi ancora in tutto il mondo è
perché tutti noi sappiamo che sono un
problema ambientale ma vorrei farmi
ragionare su un'altra prospettiva sul
fatto che l'usa e getta
è un disastro economico comprare un
soggetto vuol dire vincolarsi
continuativamente acosty che non
finiranno mai costi di acquisto
distribuzione e poi costruì smaltimento
di raccolta e di smaltimento è evidente
che investire su oggetti che durano nel
tempo è più conveniente a una certa
arrivi al break even e da lì in poi
zelig o di graz
se quindi qua e in tantissime altre
parti del mondo ci stava interrogando su
come uscire dal usa e getta
la risposta non è economica ma bisogna
cercare di costare meno degli usa e
getta
bisogna chiedersi seriamente perché
siamo dipendenti da dal mondo gli usa e
getta
e la risposta è che richiede una
funzionalità è che l'usa e getta
è comodo torniamo al bicchiere se noi
concepiamo un bicchiere come il
packaging della nostra birra
una volta finita la birra la cosa giusta
da fare buttare via il bicchiere sua
base di questo ragionamento o di tanti
altri ragionamenti affini nel 2017 io e
stefano fraioli capimmo che facendo dei
bicchieri degli oggetti coscienti
forse potremmo aggiungere quella
funzionalità per farle diventare
qualcosa di più di un packaging quindi
dargli un senso di esistere anche dopo
che abbia finito la birra e quindi
evitarne lo spreco sulla base di questa
convinzione ci licenziamo dai nostri
lavori e decidemmo di fare questa idea
un'impresa per prima cosa organizziamo
un bicchiere virtualmente
indistruttibile un bicchiere flessibile
che resiste a temperature in modo che
possa ospitare una coscienza alla storia
quanto più possibile nel tempo per
seconda cosa
trovammo una soluzione tecnica per dare
ad ogni nostro bicchiere un'anima lo
abbiamo fatto inserendo un piccolo chip
suoni nostro bicchiere che è in grado di
interagire con l'ambiente circostante e
con gli smartphone dei portatori è molto
più di questo facciamo anche una una
rete nel corso del tempo in grado di
mettere in contatto tutti i bicchieri e
quindi tutti i portatori come terza cosa
cercammo dei partner economici e di
mercato in genere con cui portare questa
idea sul mercato e gli domando
praticamente subito
ma la cosa per noi più sbalorditiva
dall'inizio sul fatto che alla prima
uscita già alla primissima uscita nel
lontano aprile 2018
il prodotto il bicchiere cosciente
funzionale le persone lo utilizzavano
per avere un'interazione con l'ambiente
per conoscere altre persone per
scambiarsi i contenuti
oggi la nostra piattaforma le persone si
scambiano dei drink in app con un clic
sulla base della comunità creata e è
rilevata dai nostri bicchieri nessuna
delle persone che usa i nostri bicchieri
li interpreta come dei packaging e
infatti nessuno
la cosa forse però se più significativa
è il fatto che pochissime persone che
usano il nostro bicchiere lo fanno con
l'intento esplicito di risparmiare la
plastica lo usano e lo riusano perché
gli serve perché una cosa che serve a
relazionarsi con gli altri
questo secondo me è molto interessante
perché dimostra che c'è una forma di
sostenibilità che non è figlia di una
rinuncia o di un atto di carità ma è
l'attuale conseguenza di un innovazione
di prodotto pensato meglio la
generazione dei miei nonni ha inventato
l'usa e getta ha inventato la plastica
la generazione di miei genitori sacasa
conto che può essere un problema a lungo
termine ma la mia generazione è la prima
chiamata sporcarsi le mani per cercare
di rimetterci in carreggiata di ripagare
un debito che abbiamo un contratto già
due generazioni fa
noi lo facciamo la degenerazione lo fa
continuamente ci sono tantissimi ragazzi
che come me è come stefano come uk a
tutti i nostri collaboratori
ogni giorno si licenziano da lavori ben
pagati e sicuri per rischiare e di
innovare qualcosa un prodotto un
servizio in compaq con compatibilità
profonda con con sostenibilità
non siamo matti non siamo noi non siamo
volontari non lo facciamo per
beneficenza la mia generazione ha la
pretesa di creare ricchezza benessere
sviluppo tecnologia posti di lavoro ma
in un modo che non distrugga l'ambiente
in cui andiamo a fare il kayak è una
scommessa importante è la scommessa sul
fatto che la nostra civiltà la nostra
economia possa includere la natura senza
devastarla e della scommessa che abbiamo
già intrapreso
siamo nel mezzo della via per arrivare
in fondo c'è ancora tanto ma proprio
ancora tanto da pagaiare grazie
[Musica]